FIRST, HOW THE GOP WALLED OFF
TRUMP, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
NOW, WHAT ARE THESE PEOPLE WHY
ARE THEY SMILING ABOUT THE $1.3
TRILLION PACKAGE PASSED BY THE
HOUSE TODAY?
CHUCK SCHUMER, 134R5I7B YOUR
JOY.
>> THIS SPENDING AGREEMENT
BRINGS THE ERA OF US ATERITY TO
AN UNCEREMONIOUS END.
WE DEMOCRATS ARE HAPPY WITH WHAT
WE'RE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH ON A
NUMBER OF PRIORITIES, THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE FOUGHT FOR ALL
ALONG.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS ARE THRILLED
BECAUSE THEY'RE ABOUT TO SECURE
RUNAWAY SPENDING THAT WAS OUT OF
REACH EVEN UNDER OBAMA.
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING IS
SKYROCKETING.
NO MORE BUDGET CAPS FOR THIS
GANG.
MEANWHILE, REPUBLICANS ARE
TRIPPING ALL OVER THEMSELVES.
HAVE YOUSTEIN THIS?
TRYING TO JUSTIFY THIS
BOONDOGGLE.
I REALIZE THEY'RE UP AGAINST, AS
USUAL, GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, BUT
THE LARGEST MILITARY EXPENDITURE
IN 14 YEARS, AND AN EXPLOSION IN
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING IS NOT
GOING TO PAVE THE WAY TO VICTORY
IN NOVEMBER.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
INCREASE MILITARY FUNDING THIS
MUCH, HOW ABOUT EVEN THE
PRETENLS OF SOMETHING TO OFFSET
SOME OF THAT WITH SPENDING CUTS.
ONCE A FISCAL HAWK WHEN IN
CONGRESS, BUDGET DIRECTOR MICK
MULVANEY TRIED TO SELL THIS
ROSIN PIECE OF FISH.
>> WE'VE TALKED FOR THE LAST, I
DON'T KNOW, THREE, FOUR, FIVE,
SIX MONTHS ABOUT TRYING TO GET
THE PRESIDENT'S PRIORITIES
FUNDED.
AND THIS OMNIBUS BILL DOES THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BILL, WE
HAVE TO WEIGH WHAT WE ASKED FOR
AND WHAT WE HAD TO GIVE AWAY TO
GET IT.
IS IT PERFECT NO.
IS IT EXACTLY WHAT WE ASKED FOR,
NO.
WERE WE EVER GOING ON GET THAT,
THAT'S NOT HOW THE PROCESS
WORKS.
>> Laura: THANKS FOR THE
TUTORIAL.
WHEN YOU AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
GIVEN YOU BOTH HOUSES OF
CONGRESS, AND THE WHITE HOUSE,
WLA YOU WHAT YOU SAID YOU
NEEDED, IT SHOULD BE THE WAY THE
PROCESS WORKS DIRECTOR MULVANEY.
THE GOP JUST CANNOT GET ITS ACT
TOGETHER.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT
PRESIDENT PROMISED IS NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY, WAS GETTING THAT
BORDER WALL BUILT.
DID THAT GET LOST ON THE PEOPLE
IN CONGRESS?
DID THEY NOT CATCH THE HUNDREDS
OF TIMES HE MENTIONED IT AND
DURING THE RALLIES?
HE ASKED CONGRESS FOR 1.6
BILLION TO BUILD 74 MILES OF
CONCRETE WALL.
THIS OMNIBUS ORRIE OF SPENDING
DEDICATES A PUNY $641 MILLION TO
SOMETHING CALLED BORDER
REINFORCEMENT.
SPEAKER PAUL RYAN SAYS DON'T
WORRY ABOUT IT.
>> WE FUND GOVERNMENT ONE YEAR
AT A TIME.
HOW THE BUDGET PROCESS WORKS.
WE'RE GOING TO FUND THE ONE WALL
YEAR AT A TIME, FOR THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS.
YOU NEED FENCES, CAMERAS,
ELECTRONIC DEVICES, YOU NEED THE
AERIAL DEVICES TO BE ABLE TO
PLACE IT IN THE MOUNTAINOUS
AREAS, CAN'T BUILD A WALL, NEED
CAMERAS AND DRONES UP THERE.
IT'S BORDER WALL SYSTEM.
DIFFERENT KIEMPBDZ OF WALL BASED
ON CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND.
THAT'S WHAT WE FUND.
>> Laura: THAT IS JUST
WASHINGTON SPEAK.
SENSORS, FENCING, IPHONES,
DRONES?
THIS ISN'T WHAT THE PRESIDENT
PROMISED.
HE VOWED TO BUILD A WALL.
IT IS NOT COMPLICATED.
NOW WE HAVE THE BIGGEST
SPEBDZING BILL IN HISTORY, AND
IT SETS ASIDE $640 MILLION TO
SUPPOSEDLY FUND WALL
CONSTRUCTION FOR ONE YEAR?
MY FRIENDS, I HATE TO SAY THIS,
BUT AS I SEE IT, RIGHT NOW,
TONIGHT, THE WALL IS NEVER GOING
TO HAPPEN.
AS WE'VE DUG INTO THIS AND
REALLY LOOKED INTO THIS, THIS
BILL DOESN'T FUND THE WALL AT
ALL.
IN FACT THE BILL ONLY PAYS FOR
CONSTRUCTION, I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M SAYING THIS, OF SEE-THROUGH
FENCING.
CONGRESS ACTUALLY AUTHORIZED,
REMEMBER THIS, BACK IN 2006.
THE OMNIBUS BILL FUNDS 33 MILES
OF NEW BARRIERS, AND REPLACEMENT
FENCING, FOR 59 MILES.
BUT UNDERSTAND THIS, THERE IS NO
WALL CONSTRUCTION.
ALL TOLD, YOU THE TAXPAYER, WILL
REFENCE PART OF THE BORDER FOR A
GRAND TOTAL OF, WAIT FOR IT, 92
MILES.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE?
ITS LOOKS LIKE THIS.
92 MILES.
YOU SEE THAT WHITE SPOT?
WE SHOULD HAVE MADE IT PINK.
THAT WHITE SPOT, LOOK HOW BIG
THE BORDER IS.
WHY BOTHER AT ALL?
PUT THE BIG WELCOME MAT AT THE
BORDER, DOESN'T MATTER.
IF THE REPUBLICANS LOSE THE
MID-TERMS, THE DEMOCRATS WILL
NEVER FUND THIS THING AND WILL
BE RELIANT ON PAUL RYE ANT'S
SENSORS AND A FEW DRONES AND
REPLACEMENT FENCING TO PROTECT
AMERICA.
I WILL REPEAT, THIS IS NOT WHAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE VOTED FOR.
YOU KNOW WHAT REALLY GETS ME?
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT TO THE
PRESIDENT.
HE KNEW HOW TO WIN THIS
ELECTION.
THE REPUBLICANS IN THE SWAMP
WANT TO TAKE IT AWAY FROM HIM.
LAST WEEK HE WAS AT THE BORDER
INSPECTING WALL PROTOTYPES WHEN
HE SAID THIS.
>> President Trump: THE FENCE,
IT IS A VERY POWERFUL FENCE, NOT
DOING THE TRICK.
THEY CUT HOLES IN IT.
THEN THEY'RE PATCHING HOMES ALL
THE TIME.
YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF HOLES CUT
IN AND PAMPED.
SO THE FENCE IS NOT STRONG
ENOUGH, NOT THE RIGHT IDEA.
BUT FOR THOSE PEOPLE, IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A WALL SYSTEM, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE A COUNTRY.
>> Laura: OKAY, I AGREE WITH
HIM, IT CAN'T BE FENCES THAT ARE
REPAIRED INTERMITTENTLY WITH
HOLES IN THEM.
YOU DON'T HAVE A WALL, DON'T
HAVE A COUNTRY.
TODAY THERE WAS A MEETING OF
MILLENIALS AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
PRETTY COOL.
AND IT IS GREAT TO HEAR THEIR
CONCERNS ON A VARIETY OF TOPICS.
BUT HOW ABOUT THE CONCERN THAT
THE GOVERNMENT, THIS TYPE OF
OMNIBUS SPENDING BILL, IS
MORTGAGING AWAY THEIR FUTURE?
THE MONEY THAT'S BEING SPENT AND
BORROWED AND PRINTED.
THIS IS CONGRESSMAN DAVE BRAT.
>> EVERYONE IS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE KIDS.
BUT THEY'RE NOT.
WE'RE PUTTING ALL THIS ON THE
KIDS CREDIT CARD.
INTER-GENERATIONAL THEFT, IT'S
IMMORAL, UNETHICAL, WE HAVE TO
MAKE A CHANGE.
>> Laura: WE ARE SADDLING THE
NEXT GENERATION WITH
EVER-GROWING DEBT.
AND FOR WHAT?
IF WE TRULY CARED ABOUT THE MY
LEN YALS WE WOULD FIRSTLY KEEP
THEM SACH BY IMMEDIATELY FUNDING
THE BORDER WALL TO KEEP THEM
SAFE.
THEN FIND REAL CUTS THROUGHOUT
THE FEDERAL BUDGE DON'T OFFSET
THESE RADICAL EXPENDITURES SO
THEY WOULDN'T BE STUCK AFTER THE
MILITARY HARDWARE AND THE FLIMSY
FENCE WE'RE BUYING HAVE ALL
RUSTED AWAY.
WE CAN DO BETTER, WE MUST DO